i was an intern in an i.t company based
in guwahati and i believed that with the
changing market i needed to grow and
learn constantly
i felt the need to take a digital
marketing course as it was my career
field and would help in my career
journey
after the course was over i got promoted
in the role of content marketing lead
and got a salary hike of 300
hi my name is
and i work as a content marketing lead
in 90 company based in guwahati i did a
lot of research before selecting the
course and i found that simply learn
digital marketing specialist was what i
needed i found that the modules were
explained in depth and regular updates
made the course interesting i found the
curriculum was explained well and it
provided me with in-depth knowledge of
every digital marketing domain that i
needed
the learning experience was amazing and
the instructors were very good they used
real life practical examples and the
group projects were very helpful and
flexible
i enjoyed the live classes by
instructors such as miss bernadette
chambers i found the course very
streamlined and everything went
according to plan the support team was
quick and helpful during the course
timeline and i remember none of my
batchmates faced any trouble
in the beginning i did find it was quite
hectic but being a dynamic person and
with the flexibility provided by simply
learn i managed to cover the course to
the help of study guides and projects
initially i used to study at nights and
weekends around 10 30 to 12. apart from
work i'm an internationally certified
nutrition specialist a national level
pro-bodybuilder a certified person
trainer a musician and i have also been
a district level football player i found
that simply learn helped in my personal
growth as well as it helped me brand
myself as a fitness influencer i believe
that it's never too late to start
learning
consistency is the key so improve your
knowledge and upskill yourself with time
simply learn is the best platform for
that and their modules are very helpful
and resourceful